-Thank you.
Thank you very much.
It's so great to be here.
I just met my boyfriend's son.
He's 10.
We went to the park,
and I bought him ice cream
so I'm a mom.
[ Laughter ]
It's so easy to be a mom.
I don't know
why they're always so tired.
[ Laughter ]
He's not quite used to me yet.
Like, he doesn't look at me in
the face when he talks to me
He doesn't call me by my name.
He calls me "Where's My Dad?
[ Laughter ]
It's hard to date someone with
a child when you don't have one.
It creates this
imbalance in the relationshi
because my boyfriend always ha
to take care of his son.
So I said,
"Why don't we get a dog?
So you can have your kid
and I'll have a dog."
And he's like,
"I don't want a dog."
So I was like,
"Then get rid of your son.
[ Laughter ]
My boyfriend just turned 50.
Hm.
Oh, my God.
So, uh...
I forgot he was turning 50
I went to
his 50th birthday party,
and I was like, "Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I can't believe he's almost 100.
[ Laughter ]
And now all these, like,
mean old-man thoughts
are creeping into my head.
You know, like the other day
he came up to me, and he said,
"Please live with me,"
and I said, "Please live."
[ Laughter ]
And he has really warm ski
all the time.
So I finally asked him,
I said, "Why is your skin
always so hot?"
And he said,
"I have high blood pressure.
And I said, "I like it.
I'm always cold at night.
Let's keep that salt
in your diet.
Let's keep that blood pressure
nice and high.
We're gonna save money
on blankets!"
I'm 6 feet tall.
Oh, wait, no. You can't sa
"tall" anymore. It's offensive
I am vertically obese.
[ Laughter ]
I like to eat.
I eat a lot of chicken.
My friend's like, "You need to
eat free-range chicken."
I said, "I don't care abou
the personality of my chicken.
[ Laughter ]
I like all chickens."
She said, "Free-range
is really healthy."
So, I Googled it.
I went online,
and free-range chicken
is just chicken that's free.
It's just on a field,
having a good time
with all the other chicken
and all that range.
And I was watching these
chickens, and I said to myself
"I can't eat these chickens.
They're way too happy."
[ Laughter ]
We need to eat
no-range chickens.
No-range chickens are trappe
and they want to die.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
They should put it
right on the packaging --
"no-range,
severely depressed chickens.
We were trapped in life, and now
we're trapped in this package.
50% off."
My parents just celebrated their
50th wedding anniversary.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I know. It's crazy.
I asked my dad, "What's th
secret to 50 years of marriage?"
He's like, "She won't die.
[ Laughter ]
I know my boyfriend and I
are never gonna reach
50 years of marriage.
First of all,
we're not even married,
so we can't even start counting.
And second of all, he's 50
[ Laughter ]
There's no way
he's gonna make it to 100.
Not with all that salt
I'm putting in his diet.
So, I got to bars alone
sometimes
'cause I'm not
technically a mom.
And this man approached me
out of the blue,
and he goes,
"You're awkwardly hot."
[ Laughter ]
What?
What does that even mean,
"awkwardly hot"?
I've never even heard
those two words put together
How do you even say thank yo
to "awkwardly hot"?
T-Thanks.
[ Smacks lips ]
[ Laughter, applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Is that awkwardly hot?
How much of awkwardly hot
is hot?
Men don't explain
their compliments.
One time, this man approache
me, and he goes,
[whispering] "There's somethin
about you that's sexy."
[ Normally ] And I was like,
"What is it?"
[ Laughter ]
And he's like, "Not that."
I'm Carmen Lynch.
Thank you so much!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Oh, fantastic. Look at that
Carmen Lynch!
For more, follow her
@CarmenComedian.